I'm a parlous una product manager for
kubernetes and Google container engine
there has been a dramatic shift in the
last couple of years in the ability for
enterprises to realize the speed
efficiency and scale benefits of
distributed computing whether it is in
the form of a private cloud on-premise
or public clouds at the scale of Google
container packaged apps are legitimately
portable and fast to deploy because the
packaging format provides independence
from the underlying host file system and
OS distribution so you can deploy an app
quickly and take it anywhere but
containers are only part of the solution
running applications in a sea of
distributed resources poses new
challenges for example how do you
schedule containers to utilize the
underlying resources efficiently when
those resources are unreliable how do
you automatically monitor and recover
containers and applications when they
fail how do you add and remove
containers to scale the application with
demand and with everything moving around
how do clients discover containerized
applications google open sourced
kubernetes to provide a solution for
these and other distributed computing
challenges based on over 12 years of
experience internally out-of-the-box
kubernetes automates container
scheduling health checking and recovery
replication to ensure uptime and
internal network management to ensure
service naming discovery and load
balancing the basic concepts kubernetes
uses to manage container clusters
include a pod which is a group of
containers that are always scheduled
together and have a shared networking
and storage identity pods typically
bundle an app with its helper functions
for example a web server and a file
puller a controller which is a feedback
loop that drives currents
eight towards the desired state this is
the basis for automation at many levels
in kubernetes for example replication
controllers ensure service continuity by
making sure a sufficient number of pods
are running at all times controllers are
also used for auto scaling a service is
an abstraction across pods that together
represent an application a service has a
stable IP address for the external world
thereby hiding the complexity of
dynamically scheduled pods across a
cluster services enable application
discovery networking and load balancing
lastly labels are user-defined metadata
that can be attached to any object in
kubernetes selectors can then be used to
query the object state and define
policies this enables many different
types of management operations for
example automated canary deployments or
rolling updates to name just two our
goal with kubernetes is to meet
customers where they are containers help
you deploy to any cloud kubernetes gives
you a management stack that can go
anywhere containers can the freedom to
deploy on premise in hybrid or multi
cloud environments left customers choose
based on the merits of the underlying
cloud Google container engine provides
the performance scale and efficiency of
the Google cloud platform to kubernetes
customers it is one of the easiest
fastest and most cost-effective ways to
manage containers in production today
this is why thousands of customers run
their production environments with
Google container engine now I would like
to invite one of those customers Tyler
Davis from port comm to talk about how
Google container engine has impacted
their business
I'm Tyler Davis DevOps engineer with
porch comm porches collected a massive
amount of data to provide transparency
to the home improvement industry on who
is the best professional to hire with
terabytes of data from both private and
public sources porch is able to connect
homeowners to the highest quality
professionals through the porch platform
the porch platform is present in over
1700 Lowe stores an available via the
porch retail solution on websites like
wayfair.com
and a CD stores calm for porch our
engineering objectives start with
stability and reliability website uptime
and reliability are paramount no website
needs no customers which means no
revenue similarly developer time is at a
premium kubernetes ease of deployment
accelerates everything kubernetes
reduces the time and overhead for
developers during new service
bootstrapping rolling out bug fixes and
new features and reduces maintenance
time with kubernetes we fail fast but we
fix it faster before December 2014 porch
had a monolithic service architecture as
this crude diagram shows we provision to
bear virtual machines running specific
applications often with less than 10%
utilization due to over provisioning for
unexpected demand also there were load
balancers for each application creating
multiple layers of load balancers
confusing compensating of network of
code problems deployments could take one
to two hours on average sometimes half a
day are longer with inconsistent state
for the duration of the rollout this was
an inefficient and ultimately expensive
implementation under our new
architecture client connections route
through a single Google load balancer
directly into the kubernetes cluster
there is only one load balancer instead
of up to four due to kubernetes ability
to proxy traffic between services
internally it's actually helped us
discover bugs and our own applications
which were masked by the layers of load
balancers before we currently run over a
hundred different services in the
cluster these applications are mostly
stateless synchronizing between other
services and storing State on databases
or memcache outside of the cluster the
large multi terabyte databases
configuration management systems like
chef and other strictly stateful systems
exist outside the cluster on compute
engine VMs Redis and other stateful
services are being migrated into the
cluster as we get more coffee
gke features as a result ports enjoys
the following architecture benefits
developer independence via a
self-service architecture allows
developers to go for commit to deployed
in production in less than 10 minutes
without DevOps involvement deployments
are reliable and can be rolled out or
rolled back in three minutes or less
due to the independent promotion
architecture we can and do deploy as
many as 30 to 50 times a day or more
with almost no risk and no downtime
finally kubernetes allows us to sleep
through events that would otherwise
require a 2 a.m. conference called an
engineering having work with kubernetes
for over a year in production we've
learned a few things clearly deployment
containers which only include the
minimum necessary artifacts and runtime
this will lead to faster deployments and
easier reasoning about deployment or
application failures also don't expect
kubernetes to be anything like what has
come before to your applications like
cattle designed for failures and
redundancy in the app and leverage all
the coolest features available such as
service discovery deployments and health
checks when in doubt experiment thank
you for joining us I hope these tips can
help you to quickly and reliably scale
your own architecture to learn more
visit kubernetes do